[Music]
could human civilization eventually
spread across the whole Milky Way galaxy
could we move beyond our small blue
planet to establish colonies in the
multitude of star systems out there this
question is a pretty daunting one there
are around 300 billion stars in the
galaxy which is about 160,000 light
years across
so far we've sent a single spacecraft
outside our solar system trudging along
at point zero zero six percent of the
speed of light at that rate it would
take over 2.5 billion years just to get
from one end of the galaxy to the other
and then there's the question of human
survival the gulf between stars is
simply enormous we couldn't live
sustainably on most planets and we
require a lot of resources to stay alive
and yet decades ago scholars found that
it's theoretically possible to not just
spread human civilization across the
galaxy but to do so quite quickly
without breaking any known laws of
physics their idea is based on the work
of a mathematician named John von
Neumann who designed on paper machines
that could self replicate and create new
generations of themselves
these would later come to be known as
von Neumann machines in the context of
space exploration von Neumann machines
could be built on earth and launched
into space they're the self-sufficient
machines would land on distant planets
they would then mine the available
resources and harvest energy build
replicas of themselves launch those to
the nearest planets and continue the
cycle the result is the creation of new
of probes spreading outwards into the
universe like a drop of ink in a
fishbowl scholars crunched the numbers
and found that a single von Neumann
machine traveling at 5% of the speed of
light should be able to replicate
throughout our galaxy in four million
years or less that may sound like a long
time but when you consider that our
universe is 14 billion years old on a
cosmic scale it's incredibly fast the
equivalent of about 2.5 hours in an
entire year
creating von Neumann machines would
require a few technologies we don't have
yet including advanced artificial
intelligence miniaturization and better
propulsion systems if we wanted to use
them to spread actual humans throughout
the galaxy we would need yet another
technological leap the ability to
artificially grow biological organisms
and bodies using raw elements and
genetic information regardless if in the
last billion years an alien civilization
created such a machine and set it
multiplying its way toward us our galaxy
would be swarming with them by now so
then where are all these machines some
astronomers like Carl Sagan say that
intelligent aliens wouldn't build
self-replicating machines at all they
might hurtle out of control
scavenging planets to their cores in
order to keep replicating others take
the machines absence as proof that
intelligent alien civilizations don't
exist or that they go extinct before
they can develop the necessary
technologies but all this hasn't stopped
people from imagining what it would be
like if they were out there science
fiction author David Brin writes about a
universe in which many different von
Neumann machines exist and proliferate
simultaneously some are designed to
greet young civilizations others to
locate and destroy them before they
become a threat in fact in bryn story
lungfish some von Neumann machines are
keeping a close watch over the earth
right
now waiting for us to reach a certain
level of sophistication before they make
their move for now all we have is
curiosity and theory but the next time
you look at the night sky consider that
billions of self-replicating machines
could be advancing between stars in our
galaxy right now if they exist one of
them will eventually land on earth or
maybe just maybe they're already here
[Music]